Donald Trump is what in the world of
poker or chess we call on tilt because
of the widespread reporting of these
truly terrible polling numbers that have
been released over the last 10 days or
so and I'll remind you once again
according to Donald Trump's own internal
polling and public polls as of right now
Donald Trump is losing badly in some key
2020 battleground states he's fired some
pollsters just reported that to you in
the last story he's called the polls
fake he's done everything under the Sun
to try to suppress the news of those
polls but now he is even calling Fox
News fake news this is getting very very
interesting Bret Baier on Fox News did
something which is not really a huge
deal
Bret Baier just reported what the polls
are saying including this new Fox News
poll that I told you about yesterday
which says Trump is down by nine to
Bernie and by 10 to Joe Biden in
hypothetical 2020 matchups and because
bret baier merely said we did a poll in
here's what it says Donald Trump
immediately took to Twitter and attacked
Bret Baier for spreading fake news
tweeting quote Fox News polls are always
bad for me that's not true by the way
they were against crooked Hillary also
something weird going on at Fox our
polls show us leading in all 17 swing
states that's also a lie for the record
I didn't spend 30 hours with ABC News
but rather a tiny fraction of that more
fake news Bret Baier so there are a
couple of things going on here and one
of them is exactly as I predicted months
ago and this is something serious that
we have to talk about so that we all
understand it many of you if you've been
watching this program for a while or
listening to the radio show or podcast
you know that sometimes on fox news
shepard smith or chris wallace will say
something moderately rational they'll
tell some basic uncontroversial truth
they'll counter some obvious bogus right
wing talking point and it really
shouldn't be a huge deal when someone on
the news just tells the truth but on fox
news it sort of is a big deal because it
is such a disinformation echo chamber so
when i talk about it on the show I will
say it's good that Shepard Smith told
the truth it's good that Chris Wallace
told the truth
but it's a very low bar and we have to
understand that it's very limited
opposition to an overall narrative that
is extraordinarily Pro Trump on Fox News
and the danger is that these little
instances of sanity on Fox can also open
the door for Fox to say hey look we are
fair and balanced we have multiple views
represented we have almost everything
and then on the other hand every once in
a while Shep Smith is allowed to say
something that's true
now it's absurd since a reporter Shep
Smith for example stating a fact
shouldn't be considered a balancing of
the rampant right-wing xenophobic
propaganda that Fox is riddled with but
it does sort of open the door for Fox to
take some cover under the fact that they
have Shep Smith and Chris Wallace now
along the same lines when Donald Trump
calls Brett Bayer fake news or at least
Brett Bayers report fake news that can
similarly be used to prop Fox up as hey
they're also getting slammed by Trump
Fox is no different they are under the
microscope by Trump just like CNN and
everybody else instead of the fact the
real fact the reality that the right
wing echo chamber propaganda network of
Fox News is 99% propaganda and as I said
a few months ago
depending on how 2020 goes Fox News
could abandon Trump Fox News is of
course committed to being right-wing
because that's what their donors and
their funders demand and expect they are
right-wing they will continue to be
right-wing but Fox News is not
necessarily committed to Donald Trump
Fox you might remember back in 2016
really in 2015 when the campaign started
Fox was not behind Donald Trump early in
the 2016 Republican primary there were
some big conflicts between Fox and Trump
early on now eventually when it became
clear that Donald Trump had growing
support that more and more the
Republican establishment was getting
behind Donald Trump even begrudgingly in
some sense Fox ultimately got behind
Donald Trump if Trump continues to be an
utter and total embarrassment on the
world stage but it looks like he's gonna
win reelection in 2020 Fox will stay
behind him but if it looks like Trump
will
fail as some early polls suggest he
might Fox News is not necessarily going
to stick with Trump they're about profit
and right-wing propaganda in a general
sense Trump might be the vehicle for
that propaganda but he also might not
and just to prepare you if Trump and Fox
have a falling out you need to know that
Donald Trump's network of choice is
going to become this absolutely wacked
out thing called Oh a n the one American
news network or one American news check
it out online but not with kids in the
room and not close to mealtimes because
it is truly it'll it'll turn your
stomach but Oh a n is where Trump will
go if ultimately he abandons Fox News as
the propaganda vehicle of choice make
sure you're following me on Instagram at
David Pakman and while you're there
follow the show on Instagram as well at
David Pakman show we will take a quick
break
boy it's a good program today glad
you're with me okay so Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is leaving the Trump
administration as press secretary and we
talked late last year about reports that
she was going to be leaving her position
as a completely dishonest and disgusting
press secretary at the end of 2018 that
didn't happen it took a little longer
but she is leaving at the end of this
month and she is going to be leaving the
White House and the Trump administration
in a state of total dishonesty and
embarrassment for the relationship that
the Trump administration has had to the
press corps remember that she has not
actually done a press briefing for just
under a hundred days I don't remember
the exact number but it's the first half
of I think March that she did her last
press briefing so in a sense it's a
perfect time to leave because she's
basically been missing as press
secretary for a long time this announced
of course by presidential tweet Donald
Trump putting the most positive possible
spin on it saying quote after three and
a half years our wonderful Sarah
Huckabee Sanders will be leaving the
White House at the end of the month and
going home to the great state of
Arkansas she is a very special person
with extraordinary talents who has done
an incredible job I hope she decides to
run for governor of Arkansas she would
be
fantastic Sarah thank you for a job well
done I actually can't think of any
extraordinary talent that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders possesses other than the ability
and I guess it is a sort of talent most
people would would cringe at doing it
she does have the extraordinary talent
of being able to tell absolutely
disgusting provable lies with no visible
shame or embarrassment on her facial
expression and in the context of the
Trump administration and defending what
she's had to defend for these three and
a half years I guess that does take
something akin to talent or skill and
again on the merits hilariously it
barely matters that she's leaving
because as far as the press briefings
are concerned there hasn't been one in
nearly 100 days and it's really really
important that Sarah Huckabee Sanders
actions and her role in the propaganda
machine of the Trump administration not
be sanitized in retrospect I we've
talked about how we've got to be careful
when we talk about ways in which George
W Bush was not as bad as Donald Trump in
terms of his diplomatic skills
relationships to allies whatever we
don't want to be incorrectly looking
back at Bush with rose-colored glasses
because he was a horrible war monger who
supervised absolutely terrible economic
circumstances and boneheaded military
decision after military decision but in
some ways he wasn't as bad as Trump in
the same way you know Sean Spicer was
terrible truly but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was much worse and we can't
allow her image to be retroactive
retrospectively rather sanitized she
concocted not just political lies but
just straight-up obvious lies like when
she said that when Donald Trump fired
James Comey in May of 2017 that a bunch
of people from the FBI had reached out
to her and said they liked that the
president fired James Comey that was a
complete and total lie she admitted that
that was a complete and total lie under
oath when she was interviewed by Robert
Moeller's investigation so this is
concocting a false story whole cloth not
a slip of the tongue as she called it
and I could sit here and just list a
bunch
these demonstrably false lies that she's
concocted many of you already know them
the point is she needs to be remembered
for shameless lying and Paul Waldman
wrote in The Washington Post over the
weekend about this and he said quote in
a more just world Sanders would be
shamed and shunned forever she wouldn't
be able to get a job
her neighbors would avoid her she would
be regarded with the universal contempt
she has so richly earned it's not the
world we live in
she'll be welcomed back in Arkansas as
some kind of hero she will be a top
prospect for all sorts of big companies
with nice salaries and Trump actually I
don't know if he's joking by saying she
could be governor of Arkansas she
probably will have a good shot at being
the governor of Arkansas at some point
in time her track record of lies and
deception have almost qualified her for
future riches and prominent prestigious
positions and that's a bigger problem
than her that's a bigger problem than
Trump it's a far bigger problem but when
we talk about a degenerate sycophant
we're really talking about someone
exactly like Sarah Huckabee Sanders
that's who comes to mind to me let me
know what you think about her departure
and the timing of it I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show it is a very very good show
today so this story is going to be
partially funny and it's going to be
partially serious because there are
funny things to talk about here and
serious things to talk about
there are numerous social media groups
and accounts and pages targeting both
the David Pakman show and the majority
report with sam cedar claiming to target
us from the left which have cropped up
recently one such group this is just an
example okay just to give you a sense of
what I'm talking about one such group is
a Facebook group called progressives
against Sam cedar and David Pakman and
there are some funny things on the page
for example if you look at the header
image cartoons of Sam and I a word
bubble from Sam saying Joe McCarthy 2020
and me saying yes please then there's
another group called anti McCarthyism
progressive unity against Sam cedar and
David Pakman and of course there are
endless Twitter accounts which I mute
when I see them because I don't have
time for them and
youtube comment movements pylons which
are lately targeting Sam and me from the
so-called progressive indie media but
sometimes they're targeting more people
too so sometimes Sam and I will be
targeted including Kyle kolinsky from
secular talk as being part of the
problem sometimes kyle is part of the
solution but Sam and I are part of the
problem or sometimes they will include
Tom Hartman as part of the problematic
left-wing media along with Sam and with
me but sometimes Tom Hartman is the
right type of progressive he's on the
good side of the line but Sam and I are
on the wrong side of the line but the
point here is that who is on which side
of the line changes and it depends
hugely on which so-called progressives
are drawing that line and that's not
hugely surprising now I'm trying to
think of like how to even start with
this because when you see something like
this progressives united against David
Pakman and Sam cedar there are a bunch
of obvious questions that we should be
asking question one is are these groups
really people who are on the Left who
dislike Sam and who dislike me or are
they right-wing astroturf that's a
question to be asked second who is it
that these so-called progressives
support if Sam and I are the problems
who are the right progressives that
should be supported according according
to the people who are creating these
groups targeting Sam and targeting me
and thirdly what does it mean about the
progressive movement that more and more
stuff like this type of infighting and
targeting is cropping up so here's the
common trends I'm seeing when you look
at the anti David and Sam pages number
one many of them have a ton of Pro Jimmy
Dore content posted as examples of the
right kind of leftism
okay so if we look at progressives
against Sam cedar and David Pakman a
whole bunch of the posts are Jimmy door
clips which I believe is meant to imply
that Jimmy's the right kind of
progressive and Sam and I are the wrong
types of progressive so right off the
bat you start to get a picture of this
anti Sam and David movement as at least
partially a Pro Jimmy door movement
often these pages and particularly the
Twitter accounts also have a lot
Pro tulsi gabbard content if you don't
know Tulsi gabbard's she is a
presidential candidate currently polling
about 0.6 percent I believe so that's
another sort of trend that exists and
then typically there's a lot of Russia
Gate denialism that is in a lot of these
anti David anti Sam pages along the
lines of we can't believe anything
Muller says other than when Muller said
no collusion but all the stuff about
obstruction and election interference
and WikiLeaks is involvement from the
Moller report that stuff we don't
believe but we can definitely trust
Muller that Trump did nothing wrong so
I'm not gonna go back and attack any
particular wing of the left I'm not
going to accuse certain leftists of not
really being left because that would be
furthering the problem that these groups
are sort of indicating exists here's my
main point if the left continues to do
this the left is going to continue to
fail on many fronts and I brought this
up on the Joe Rogan program two weeks
ago and a bunch of people misunderstood
what I was saying when people come to me
and they say David what's the real
problem with the left it's not sjw's
okay it's not campus free speech
suppression it's not toxic identity
politics those things exist and they do
exist in bits and pieces on the left and
I call them out when I see them but the
real potential problem on the left is
defining the left so rigidly that it
will fail to accomplish anything major
because it will keep out way too many
people who share most of our goals and
there's a really good article by Joshua
sites in Politico from June 1st called
progressives should read progressive
history so they don't blow it this time
and it points out that there are major
problems to solve right now
in American society in the American
economy but if progressives want to
achieve change we need to understand how
past movements have succeeded and the
article looks at the progressive
movement of the early 1900s and it looks
at the New Deal coalition of the 1930s
and it also looks at the conservative
coalition of the 70s and 80s which was
really successful for conservatives and
I won't go into the specifics of the
three movements
right now but the general thing they did
right is they were inclusive of people
who disagreed on some of what should be
the agenda but they agreed on enough of
the important stuff that they were able
to get really important change to happen
and that's my real concern about the
progressive movement right now and I'm
going to talk about this at the end of
the week in audience questions the lines
are being drawn too narrowly and people
who could work together on for example
70% of their agenda or 80% of their
agenda are going to end up doing nothing
because they're concerned about making
pages targeting other people on the
basis of the 10 or 20% that they
disagree on one example okay
small but growing is this divided on the
left between social democracy and
socialism it's a great debate
philosophically it's a great debate
economically I'm glad to have that
debate social democracy versus socialism
I've engaged in that debate on the show
the u.s. is not going to become
socialist any time soon and before the
US will have a reasonable possibility of
becoming socialist it's going to have to
move significantly in the direction of
social democracy the reforms that are
possible in the immediate are reforms
that are social democracy reforms which
should appeal to the actual socialists
socializing healthcare raising the
standard of living for the bottom via
taxation at the top end of financial
transactions that had no value to the
economy and education what is the point
in redirecting energy away from making
those changes which both Social
Democrats and socialists agree on in
order to debate and draw the lines
between you're either with the
socialists or you're against us this is
stupid
okay the left will lose if that's what
they do let me give another example that
applies to me I am against intervention
in Venezuela 100% I've said it a hundred
times but I also think that the Chavez's
madara regimes have been terrible for
Venezuela okay we agree on the Left
almost 100% about being against military
intervention in Venezuela and
when I bring up but by the way I don't
like Maduro and Chavez and here's why
and I think that they have been
disastrous plunderers for Venezuela all
of a sudden I'm on the wrong side when
it comes to the intervention piece and
people are ignoring the fact that I'm
right here with you I'm against military
intervention in Venezuela let's work
together on that because the debate over
Chavez and Maduro has less in terms of
immediate consequences than that about
American intervention in Venezuela
so let's table some of the less
mmediately relevant discussions let's
actually get stuff done that we all
agree about and let's not draw the lines
too rigidly because that's the problem I
see on the left not free speech campus
stuff or sjw's or whatever those
problems exist I call them out they're
relatively small but anyway have fun
with the anti sam cedar anti David
Pakman groups but you are doing damage
to the movement unfortunately we've been
wondering whether Barack Obama will
endorse one of the Democratic primary
candidates for 2020 maybe his former
Vice President Joe Biden before the
primary is over and it's not clear that
Barack Obama is going to get involved in
this primary but we now have heard from
Trump's former adviser Valerie Jarrett
who says that number one Barack Obama is
quote very concerned about what is going
on in the United States read Trump and
that he will be getting involved in the
2020 campaign in some form with the goal
of ultimately defeating the president
Donald Trump let's assume she's right
okay so what we're saying this is what
Valerie Jarrett has said President Obama
thinks and will do and I can't imagine
she would speak without knowing that for
a fact so let's imagine that it's true
for the purposes of our discussion today
it appears as though Barack Obama does
not plan on getting involved in the
primary and my thought is that this is
the right decision and I'm gonna tell
you why I'm guessing Barack Obama
understands and everybody around Barack
Obama understands realizes that there's
very little upside long-term for
Democrats of Barack Obama getting
involved in the primary now this is not
why didn't Elizabeth Warren endorsed
Bernie during the primary if she like
him so much Obama's relationship to the
presidency and candidates is very
different than that of Elizabeth
Warren's number one Barack Obama was
President of the United States number
two one of the current Democratic
primary candidates is Barack Obama's
former vice president so I see this as a
no win for Barack Obama to get involved
in the primary if Obama comes out and
endorses Joe Biden it furthers the DNC
establishment narrative it opens up the
door to more claims of an unbalanced
primary in which the DNC or quote
establishment Democrats are meddling and
whether it's true or not a former
president saying that he wants his
former VP to be the nominee the election
right after the DNC screwed Bernie in
favor of Hillary it doesn't look good so
whatever gain might be calculated for
Barack Obama to come out now and endorse
Joe Biden I think has far more negatives
outweigh it if Obama not endorses Biden
during the primary and Biden does not
get the nomination then there's the
question of whether Barack Obama has
weakened the power of his endorsement by
initially endorsing somebody who doesn't
win and then having to go out and
campaign for somebody that he didn't
endorse during the primary if instead of
Joe Biden Barack Obama prefers somebody
else
imagine that Barack Obama prefers Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or whoever
and he endorses them during the primary
and Biden ends up winning who is of
course leading in the polls right now
it's the same problem in Reverse how
strong is Obama support of Biden as the
nominee if Obama supported Sanders
during the primary and I understand that
many politicians endorse one person
during the primary that person loses
then they support somebody else it is
different when you are a former
president and it is different when one
of the candidates is your former vice
president so to me this is fine okay
support who you like in the primary and
then you vote to defeat Trump no matter
who the nominee is from the people that
are running but the perception of it not
going right for Barack Obama wouldn't be
good President Obama imagined that he
has built up a sort of specific amount
of political capital it's a
odd okay the former president who has
seen very favorably by Americans has a
lot of political capital but it's not
unlimited political capital and I don't
believe that there is a long-term gain
for Barack Obama to get involved in the
primary in the context of working to
defeat Donald Trump which is the goal
what Obama should do during the primary
it's two things number one demand and
lobby for an open transparent primary to
the extent that he's willing to do that
and it may not be a significant extent
and I understand that and number two
Barack Obama during the primary should
be working to push back against all of
the voter suppression efforts from
Republicans to ensure that when the time
comes to vote in November of 2020 every
vote is counted everyone who wants to
vote gets to vote and have their votes
counted which will help the eventual
Democratic nominee when the time comes
for the DNC to formally nominate the
winner of the primary at the convention
Barack Obama should be there introducing
them and speaking at the DNC and
rallying the troops but there is not an
advantage to him getting involved at
this point in the primary endorsing
somebody now there are some really low
energy beta comments from Republicans
saying that it's unbecoming of a
president a former president to get
involved at all in the presidential race
and that it looks bad
give me a break okay you're pathetic
it's unbecoming to have a president like
Trump embarrassing the country day in
and day out on the national stage Barack
Obama is concerned about the future of
this country and he wants to work to
change that trajectory or at least
according to Valerie Jarrett he's
planning on working to change that and
he should be applauded for it but I
completely understand why Barack Obama
is not not likely to get involved in
this primary and I actually agree with
that decision for the strategic reasons
that I've outlined if you disagree with
my conclusion or if you simply disagree
with how I've built up that conclusion I
want to hear from you I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
one of the biggest geopolitical blunders
of this administration has been Donald
Trump bailing on the Iran nuclear deal
in
without Iran having violated the deal
which was of course signed under
President Barack Obama and you might
remember as many people did Trump
opposed the deal under Obama
lots of right-wingers did that and
that's fine but once the deal signed
willy-nilly canceling it when you're
elected president absent any cause to do
so based on what's in the deal is not a
good idea and I've said this before if
other countries can't trust that the
United States is going to stick to the
deals that we make even when a president
changes when the party in the
controlling the White House changes
there is no incentive to deal with us
there is no incentive to treat us
correctly it's geopolitically a disaster
and that's exactly what it has been I
also told you several weeks ago that
Iran completely predictably is now
resuming nuclear research and
development possibly for nuclear energy
possibly for nuclear weapons which of
course I don't want them to have but the
point is they're resuming enrichment of
uranium which I don't want them to do
but given the circumstances it's
perfectly logical it's perfectly
rational and it's what we would expect
that they would do Iran knows that if
they are not if the United States has
bailed on the Iran nuclear deal they are
better off no matter what happens in the
future starting to enrich uranium again
either they start enriching uranium so
that in the future it becomes a
negotiating point for a future deal or
they start enriching uranium either to
develop nuclear power or nuclear weapons
because if they understand history they
know that historically having nuclear
weapons has been a strong positioning
item positioning it has been strong for
the positioning of nations and there are
numerous examples that we can look at
and those include we've talked about
Iraq we've talked about many others so
it's completely predictable that it's
what Iran would do I don't want them to
do it but I get why they're doing it and
what Donald Trump is now doing is trying
to have it both ways
Trump has bailed on the deal he has
pulled the United States out of the Iran
nuclear deal but at the same time is
demanding that Iran stick to the deal
unless they want
face further consequences for not
sticking to the deal and here's the
loophole that the Trump administration
is trying to use to justify this
nonsense what the u.s. is saying is that
even though we pulled out of the deal
there are other countries that are still
in the deal and this is of course the
height of absurdity the Donald Trump
backed the United States out of the Iran
nuclear deal
it was a coalition deal so the argument
they're making is the u.s. is out but
Iran is still in the deal with the UK
and with France and with Germany and of
course on a technical level that may be
but then it's up to those countries to
demand that Iran comply Donald Trump and
the United States have no credibility
whatsoever to even ask for that at this
point in time and even worse is that the
United States has actually made it
almost impossible for the other
countries to keep working with Iran on
compliance so Donald Trump has sort of
put himself into a very strange and
idiotic corner but specifically a corner
that lacks all credibility on the issue
and unfortunately and this really is a
problem there are news outlets that are
reporting that Iran would be in
violation of the deal if they do this or
if they did that Trump ripped up the
agreement it makes it hard for other
countries to keep it going but when
Donald Trump does that and then yet he
still insists that Iran has to stick
with the deal and more importantly maybe
we're used to Trump's hypocrisy and
idiocy and ignorance domestically but
geopolitically this starts to put Europe
once again potentially at odds with the
United States because ultimately those
other countries the European signatories
to the Iran deal might have to say we
agree with the u.s. even though Trump
backed out the deal with us is still on
and Iran needs to abide by it that would
be taking Trump's side when it comes to
this disagreement or the European
signatories might say even though this
is a multi-part deal by ripping it up as
far as American involvement the deal is
effectively dead and we really have no
sort of compliance authority
to enforce that Iran stick to it and
this is yet another one of these
examples of how the United States will
be pitted against Europe and we've
talked about this before when the US and
Europe are at odds this is a win for
Putin who wants to put a wedge between
the United States and our allies a lot
of Putin's prerogatives and priorities
when it comes to NATO relate to driving
a wedge between the United States and
Europe this relates to so much of what
we've been talking about over the last
couple of years and it's not this
cartoonish Trump and Putin colluding
thing it's that Donald Trump doesn't
even have the wherewithal and the
knowledge and the intelligence quite
frankly to even understand the ways in
which his actions and statements
regarding Europe and other allies and
his looking away when it's convenient to
look away from authoritarian leaders
doing absolutely terrible things
it all fits into a politic that benefits
Vladimir Putin in a world in which
Russia and China are increasingly
aligned to the detriment of the United
States as sort of the third leg of the
nuclear of the superpowers the three
growing geopolitical superpowers and
we've talked about this many many times
before it doesn't have to be Trump
colluding with Putin to be executing a
politic that benefits Putin in ways that
Russia has been thinking about and
talking about at least for two-plus
decades if not longer this in the end is
going to be what it's about we'd be
better off if Donald Trump had not
backed out of the deal Iran would be
further back in their nuclear
development everyone would be safer with
an Iran that is still part of the deal
and complying with the Iran nuclear deal
instead we have an Iran that is newly
invigorated in its nuclear development
there are new discussions of war with
Iran on the table and it's absolutely
absurd and utterly embarrassing on the
national stage which has basically been
the theme of this administration if you
disagree let me know I want to hear from
you about the Iran nuclear deal about it
actions in resuming enrichment of
uranium about the context in which Putin
likes the idea of the United States at
odds with Europe about what does or
doesn't Iran have to do with regard to
what is remaining the tatters of the
Iran nuclear deal let me know what you
think we've talked before about how
during the Obama administration
Republicans insisted in baseless
conspiracy theories relating to
President Obama about Obama planning to
or wanting to or scheming to stay in
power longer than two presidential terms
sometimes it would be Obama is going to
declare martial law to justify
suspending the 2016 election sometimes
it was Obama is going to change the
Constitution so that presidents can have
three terms or unlimited terms or
whatever and anyone who had a good head
on their shoulders realized that from
day one it was absolutely ridiculous and
completely not based in fact but there
were lots of Republicans that fell for
that conspiracy just like they fell for
the Trump fomented birther conspiracy
theories so this unfortunately was a
topic of discussion among certain
enclaves of the right while Barack Obama
was President Obama will not relinquish
power he will do everything under the
under the Sun possible to try to stay in
power beyond 2016 of course it never
happened and that was completely
predictable Donald Trump on the other
hand has actually signaled that he at
least has aspirations to more than two
presidential terms and Donald Trump also
has serious authoritarian tendencies and
I'm not going to rehash the full list of
examples here but lately Donald Trump
keeps quote joking about serving more
than two presidential terms and to be
clear I've said it before I don't think
Donald Trump would get away with it if
he tried but Donald Trump continues to
reference this idea of staying in power
for more than eight years and over the
weekend Trump sort of again alluded to
this on Twitter take a look saying quote
a poll should be done on which is the
more dishonest and deceitful newspaper
the failing New York Times or the Amazon
lobbyists Washington Post they are both
a disgrace to our country the enemy of
the people but I just can't seem to
figure out which is
worse the good news is that at the end
of six years after America has been made
great again and I leave the beautiful
white house do you think the people
would demand that I stay longer Keep
America great both of these horrible
papers will click quickly go out of
business and be forever gone so by
itself this is like nothing it's just
another dumb tweet from the president
sort of alluding to staying longer than
eight years in the White House but
remember the context remember what
Donald Trump said before the 2016
election he said he might not accept the
results of the 2016 election if they
said that Hillary Clinton had won and by
the way he hasn't accepted the popular
vote results yes he did win electoral II
he lost the popular vote badly by more
than any recent president has lost the
popular vote and he doesn't accept that
he has insisted that three to five
million people voted illegally for
Hillary Clinton
remember when Donald Trump said last
year behind closed doors two Republican
donors that he likes what the Chinese
president has done saying quote he's now
president for life president for life
no he's great and look he was able to do
that I think it's great maybe we'll have
to give it a shot someday once again the
tendency the appeal to Donald Trump of
the presidency possibly for him lasting
longer than eight years so as crystal is
arrow in a recent CNN op-ed I do not
think that Donald Trump is going to try
to change the Constitution to stay in
power beyond two terms if he wins
re-election let's not do what
Republicans did under Barack Obama and
go crazy with all of these absurd
conspiracy theories I do believe that
Donald Trump is likely to question the
20/20 results if he loses and to at
least try to make the case that he was
not fairly defeated and he's already
started to lay the groundwork for that
and I do expect Donald Trump to dance
around with the idea if he wins
re-election in 2020 that maybe he should
remain in power beyond that but I don't
think that it's going to succeed and I
don't think that there's going to be any
serious case that Trump makes that would
actually challenge the
sort of framework which limits
presidents to eight years Trump yes is a
major authoritarian Trump yes must get
what he wants yes Trump is the epitome
of the sort of entitled rich kid but is
he going to actually try to forcefully
stay in power I believe the answer is no
and even if he does there is no way that
he could pull it off even if he actually
tries to do that the point is if you
were one of the people before 2016
saying that Barack Obama is going to try
to stay in power how can you not be
saying the same thing about Donald Trump
because Donald Trump has actually shown
us that behind the curtain he likes the
idea of more than eight years as
president and he is more than willing to
question the validity and
trustworthiness of election results when
the results simply don't suit him as
that entitled rich kid that he has been
his entire life all I'm saying is
there's a double standard there I don't
believe that this is a real risk that
Donald Trump is going to try to carry
out all right I hope everybody had a
good weekend because it's it's getting
going it's almost time for the first
2020 Democratic primary debates this
thing is really getting going in earnest
I guess we could say and there are a lot
of different things I want to talk about
related to this first series debate one
is really two debates okay there are 20
candidates who are participating in the
first debate which will be on NBC News
at the end of next week
will I be live-streaming commentary of
the debates maybe
we'll see we'll see a depends on if
there's interest that's a lot of has a
lot of live streaming in addition to the
regular show but there's a good chance I
will do it so the reason they're
splitting this up into two parts even
though it's debate number one is that
it's not practical to have 20 people
debate all at once on one stage so
they're splitting it into debate 1a
which will be next Wednesday the 26th
and then debate 1b which will be
Thursday the 27th 10 candidates on each
part so the obvious question who gets to
be in part one who gets to be in part
two and one thing that the DNC
and NBC News I guess together wanted to
avoid is the idea of a sort of top-tier
debate
versus the kids table so to speak and
really mix up people that are polling
well and people that are polling less
well and the way that NBC News says they
did it is by separating the candidates
into two groups the met the the top
polling people and the lesser well
polling people and including some from
both groups in both debates to make sure
that there is some mix now the
requirements to even qualify for this
debate
were either one percent in three
qualified polls or 65 thousand donors
with certain minimums per state and a
certain minimum number of states the
particulars don't so much matter the
important thing is that lots of people
who would not have made it on the basis
of polling did receive the sufficient
number of donations and on that basis
are going to be participating in the
debates which i think is good if you're
able to show I mean I hate that money
plays the role that it plays in our
elections but just because you're not
polling 1% if you otherwise are
generating a significant number of
donations I do think you should be
allowed to participate I think a lot of
these people polling under 1 and under 2
are going bye-bye before the next series
of debates but that's the whole point of
doing these things many of these people
will be gone from the next set of
debates unless they really impress the
audience in these first debates and
that's a great thing so let's look at
the list what you will notice is that on
Wednesday June 26th
you have Cory Booker Elizabeth Warren
Beto O'Rourke Amy Klobuchar John Delaney
Tulsi Gabbard who Leon Castro
Tim Ryan Bill DeBlasio and Washington
governor jay Inslee effectively what has
happened is that the first debate is
basically Elizabeth Warren versus a
bunch of people polling almost nothing
plus Cory Booker and beto who are
polling a couple of points but don't
seem to have any reasonable shot in my
mind at impressing people so sincerely
and so overwhelmingly that they are
going to be in this thing we'll talk in
a second whether that would be good for
Elizabeth Warren or not and then in the
second night of these debates you have
the heavier hitter frontrunner you've
got Bernie Sanders and Kamala Harris of
course Vice President Joe Biden and
Pete Buddha judge who are the
frontrunners with the exception of
Elizabeth Warren who will be on the
first night and then joining them
Michael Bennett Marianne Williamson who
I I have a hard time believing she even
really has the the financial support
required but okay I don't I'm not being
conspiratorial I'm just shocked that she
got sixty five thousand donations Eric's
wall well kirsten gillibrand Andrew yang
has made the stage which will be
interesting john hickenlooper as well so
the second night is every other
frontrunner but Elizabeth Warren meaning
Biden Sanders Budaj edge and Kamala
Harris does this help her hurt Elizabeth
Warren there's two ways to think about
it okay one approach is this is bad for
Elizabeth Warren because the second
night will have a bigger audience
because there are more big players who
want to see their favorite debate rather
than people they aren't supporting the
second night has more polling support in
the aggregate in total and so Elizabeth
Warren just is not going to get the
exposure that some of these other
candidates are going to get there's
another view though which is no this is
good for Elizabeth Warren first of all
this is the first debate of the season
meaning it's going to be very well
viewed it's gonna have a significant
audience and therefore it's not right to
assume that night two we'll have more
audience tonight one is going to have
more audience the other argument to be
made in favor of Elizabeth Warren is she
is clearly the top dog on the first
night therefore she's going to do really
well against lesser known less popular
candidates the the sort of wrinkle in
that argument is that although Elizabeth
Warren is clearly the front-runner of
the first night of candidates she's not
necessarily the best debater of that
first night because as I've spoken about
before I love Elizabeth Warren's
policy-based approach it's been helping
her in the polls will talk about those
polling numbers momentarily which
continue to improve for Elizabeth Warren
but in large stage debates I don't
actually think she's that great so it'll
be very interesting to see whether
ultimately this is good or bad for
Elizabeth Warren to be the segregated
frontrunner in night one net net net I
think it probably hurts her a little bit
I
it will give her a great opportunity to
pull some support from some of the other
people she's debating against but that
in the context of against the bigger
frontrunner like Biden and Sanders it's
a missed opportunity for her by being on
a different night but this is just the
bait one a right there's going to be a
lot of opportunities so this is this is
just the beginning what I also am really
interested in seeing is the Bernie
versus Biden dynamic in night two of the
debate which again this is next week not
this week we've just learned what the
lineups are going to be Bernie during
that Fox News Town Hall said oh Joe's a
friend of mine but we have policy
differences or whatever however it was
that he worded it that's going to be
very interesting and it's also going to
be interesting to see if any of what I
call the one-percenters explode because
there have been listen Andrew yang who I
like has a following that says as soon
as Andrew yang gets on a debate stage
with these other candidates he is going
to explode in the polling because people
are just going to absolutely love what
he has to say we'll see if that happens
I'm excited to see if that happens Tulsi
has a similar following that says as
soon as Tulsi Gabbard is given the
opportunity to debate these other
candidates she will come through as the
right path forward for the United States
of America well we're going to see very
soon she's polling I think 0.4 percent
right now or maybe it's up to like 0.7
we'll see um
jay Inslee is a guy who has almost no
support but his supporters believe that
he is really offering the best package
of policies and that as soon as America
is fully introduced to jay Inslee jay
Inslee 'he's polling is going to take
off like a rocket ship or whatever
metaphor you want to use we'll see and
I'm excited to see it and we'll talk
more about the pre debate stuff that's
going on later in the week but probably
more early early next week